und jetzt meine damen und herren schauen
wir nach berlin heute endet nämlich die
sitzungswoche des deutschen bundestags
aber für die nächsten stunden steht dort
so einiges wichtiges auf dem programm
das sie nicht verpassen sollten und sie
sehen schon mein kollege alexander
kähler der kann ihn gleich mehr darüber
berichten
er ist schon vor ort alexander fort aber
die frage inwieweit steht da heute im
politischen berlin noch etwas ganz
anderes im fokus nämlich die
korruptionsvorwürfe gegen den csu
abgeordneten georg nüßlein
ja das hat hier in berlin fast wie eine
bombe eingeschlagen georg nüßlein ist ja
nicht irgendjemand hier im bundestag
erst der stellvertretende vorsitzende
der cdu/csu-bundestagsfraktion zuständig
für wirtschaft energie und auch
gesundheit gerade während der pandemie
hat er hier oft das wort ergriffen im
bundestagsplenum konkret wird ihm
vorgeworfen bestechlichkeit bestechung
und steuerhinterziehung es geht um eine
angebliche vermittlung eines auftrags
über eine firma der nüßlein beteiligt
ist von atemschutzmasken einer
textilfirma in hessen an politische
institutionen in münchen und hier in
berlin die staatsanwaltschaft münchen
hat die ermittlungen aufgenommen
gestern wurde die immunität von georg
nüßlein aufgehoben und gleich danach
hier sein abgeordnetenbüro durchsucht
wie auch zwölf weitere objekte in
deutschland und liechtenstein auch für
georg nist land gilt natürlich zunächst
die unschuldsvermutung
im bundestag gibt es natürlich auch
'business as usual' zb das dritte steuer
hilfe gesetz in sachen corona das heute
verabschiedet werden dazu werden wir
jetzt gleich etwas mehr erfahren denn zu
diesem thema habe ich zwei gäste nämlich
ihn ab aus die finanzpolitische
sprecherin der fraktion bündnis 90 die
grünen im bundestag und hans michelbach
finanz und wirtschaftsexperte der csu
und der cdu csu fraktion und auch
stellvertretender vorsitzender der csu
landesgruppe
herr michelbach bevor wir loslegen ein
wort zu georg nüßlein aus der csu
landesleitung gestern ist kolportiert
worden man sei doch
in großes erstaunen versetzt worden auch
ob der höhe um die es da geht
vermittlungsprovision von 660.000 euro
die angeblich nicht versteuert worden
sind haben sie die vorwürfe gegen
gehören bislang an parteifreunde an
fraktionskollege auch erstaunt ja sehr
erstaunt ich eigentlich waren wir
zunächst einmal platt weil wir kennen
ihn gut und sehr integrieren kollegen
ich möchte mich an vorverurteilungen
überhaupt nicht beteiligen das muss man
jetzt aufarbeiten und die
unschuldsvermutung gilt wenn es wirklich
so die vorwürfe sich erhärten würden
wäre das schlimm sehr schlimm für das
ansehen der politik so etwas darf es
dann nicht gegen island hat die vorwürfe
als haltlos schon bezeichnet denken sie
dass er jetzt oder wissen sie schon ob
er sein amt als stellvertretender
fraktionsvorsitzender ruhen lässt nein
ich weiß dazu gar nichts wir haben ihm
gesagt er soll sich dazu erklären weil
er weiß am besten was auch ist wir
können wir können dazu moment keine
stellungnahme abgeben weil wir keine
information haben darüber zum dritten
corona steuer gesetzt haben sich die
bach das beinhaltet ja auch eine die
verlängerung der mehrwertsteuersenkung
für das essen in gaststätten von der
jahresmitte das ende nächsten jahres
ende 2022
viele kritiker halten das für falsch zu
sagen dass bevorzugt vor allem die
umsatzstarken betriebe der gastronomie
und andere bereich wie der einzelhandel
bekommen solche privilegien nicht ja
leider haben wir immer bei den hilfen
natürlich die situation dass ich einer
bevorteilte fühlt wichtig ist dass wir
insgesamt jetzt mal 80 milliarden euro
in die hand genommen haben für
wirtschaftshilfen und 20 milliarden für
die kurzarbeitsentschädigung
kurzarbeitergeld so dass es kein anderes
land gibt es so viel
mittel in die finanzmittel in die hand
nimmt und das muss natürlich recht
verteilt werden
die gastronomie hat mit dieser umsatz
entschädigung von 75 prozent und mit der
mehrwertsteuerreduzierung einen sicher
guten weg bekommen
hier sind aber auch sehr viele kleine
und mittlere betriebe wie notwendig sind
und die für die gesamte wirtschaft
stellung nur auch zu erhalten sind
rathaus jetzt könne man ja umgekehrt
sagen die gastronomie das war einer der
ersten bereiche der locker und gehen
musste gleich zweimal und wird
wahrscheinlich als einer der ältesten
wieder aufmachen dürfen ist das sowas
wie eine ausgleichende gerechtigkeit
diese mehrwertsteuersenkung die
mehrwertsteuersenkung ist jetzt nicht
wirklich genial weil es eben jetzt
momentan gar nicht hilft und momentan
ist zu und wenn man nichts verkauft oder
wenig verkauft dann hilft einem diese
fortführung nichts von daher hätten wir
uns da was anderes gewünscht und es ist
auch kein offenes geheimnis dass gerade
diese forderung ein evergreen der
gastronomie ist nun das fordern die
schon seit jahren die haben dass eine
entsprechende verlängerung bekommen
von daher haben sie da gut gearbeitet
aber wirklich helfen in der breite wird
das nicht von daher ist das sehr viel
geld wird herausgeschmissen was man
besser verwenden kann
michelbach dieses gesetz beinhaltet auch
einen erneuten kinderbonus von 150 euro
nach 300 euro im vergangenen jahr ist
das ausreichend als kinder hilfe für
familien und kinder deutlich
alles zu wenig kann man sagen aber wir
müssen uns natürlich
doch nach den wirtschaftlichen und
finanziellen möglichkeiten kümmern
zunächst einmal ist es ganz wichtig dass
wir die arbeitsplätze erhalten das geht
durch die kurzarbeit entschädigung und
es geht natürlich auch insbesondere
durch die haltung der betriebe grieche
den verlust rückschlag den wir jetzt als
steuerliche hilfsmaßnahmen beschlossen
haben aber auch natürlich durch die
vielfältigen staatshilfen also ich
glaube die hpa lose muss stattfinden
kinderbonus auf der einen seite erhalt
von arbeitsplätzen
auf der anderen seite
rathaus was gibt es nur noch für
möglichkeiten familien mit kindern zu
unterstützen
die balance stimmt eben nicht nur der
lotter und da wird jetzt schon länger
als der in erster linie gehabt haben im
ersten block daran gab es 300 euro
einmalig diesmal sind es nur 150 und das
ist natürlich wirklich nicht viel mehr
als ein tropfen auf den heißen stein
es ist gut dass diese 150 euro einmalig
auch an hartz iv empfänger gehen anders
als beim thema kindergeld aber natürlich
ist das absurd wenig nun wir haben die
schulen sind nach wie vor zu
beziehungsweise im teilbetrieb und das
heißt eben für ganz ganz viele familien
mit kindern sie sind vollständig
abgehängt deswegen war gab es ja gerade
der letzten woche einen appell von über
40 gewerkschaften und sozialverbänden
die gesagt haben
diese 150 euro gerade für die sozial
schwächsten sind absurd wenig wir
brauchen mindestens 100 euro pro monat
für erwachsene mehr und 60 euro pro
kinder weil ja auch ganz viele
infrastrukturleistungen weggefallen sind
schulessen jetzt weggefallen andere
unterstützungsleistungen sind
weggefallen
die digitale infrastruktur für die
schulen funktioniert nicht von daher ist
das wirklich absurd wenig und ansonsten
erleben wir auch einiges von dem gesetz
ist okay ja aber zum team das wichtigste
effizienteste instrument verlust
zurücktragen in der vernünftigen art und
weise über vier jahre ist nach wie vor
nicht in dem gesetz
stattdessen haben wir nach wie vor ein
chaos bei den wirtschafts hilfen kein
mensch durch gezahlt wird immer noch nur
kleckerweise und das alles ist natürlich
keine gute situation thema weil ich
jetzt anfangen verlust drückt ist ein
wortungetüm aber dank der pandemie weiß
man jetzt ungefähr was das ist das heißt
also man kann verluste die man jetzt
durch die pandemie erleidet mit den
steuern die man auf gewinne der vorjahre
erzielt hat verrechnen ist also eine
steuererleichterung für die betriebe die
sind bei 10 millionen ist dieser betrag
gedeckelt bei zusammenveranlagung bei 20
millionen das ist der wirtschaft zu
wenig müsste man diesen betrag noch
erhöhen
es ist zum einen zu wenig war vor allen
dingen nützt ja nichts wenn man eben
diese wenn man zur verrechnung nur die
gewinne aus dem letzten jahr benutzen
kann wir wissen 2020 weiß nicht dass
gewinnträchtigste jahr deswegen haben
wir grünen gesagt
wichtig ist dass man eben auch von den
gewinnen der jahre davor profitieren
kann
dann hat man tatsächlich eine konkrete
direkte entlastung direkte liquidität
und vor allen dingen werden damit
natürlich zielgenau
die unternehmen unterstützen die
eigentlich gesund sind die allein durch
die pandemie sozusagen eingeschränkt
sind die eben in den jahren 1918 17 auch
gewinne gemacht haben
da verweigert sich nach wie vor die
bundesregierung beziehungsweise diese
koalition damit führen sich diese
unternehmen zu recht im stich gelassen
ich mache jetzt wird er von der
wirtschaftskrise der betrag diese zehn
millionen deckelung beim verlust druck
da das so niedrig wie soll man im
prinzip ganz abschaffen und vor allem
auch zeitlich zurück mehrere jahre
diese gewinne verrechnen können ist das
eine richtige einstellung und hat
vielleicht der bundeswirtschaftsminister
peter altmaier da gegenüber dem
koalitionspartner gegenüber olaf scholz
der das nicht so gut fand nicht hart
genug verhandelt und das kann es
natürlich dass der bundesfinanzminister
den deckel auf die kasse führt aber es
wichtig ist dass wir den verlust
rückfragen unter prozent in der summe
erhöht haben vor war 5 millionen 10
millionen
und wir müssen sehen dass wir
insbesondere ja die mittelständischen
strukturen damit ansprechen wollen da
den anreiz schaffen wollen
das ist die effizienteste
liquiditätshilfe die unternehmen
überhaupt bekommen können ohne dass sie
den bürokratischen weg über die
staatshilfen beantragen sondern hier
sind firmen begünstigt die liquidität
sofort zu schaffen indem sie also
steuern die sie bezahlt haben
zurückbekommen durch die verluste durch
den verlust drückt also ich denke das
ist der effizienteste weg und wir müssen
das insbesondere für die
mittelständischen strukturen machen
wir haben ja bei großbetrieben auch die
kfw kredite und da haben wir ja bei
lufthansa bei kaufhof karstadt und so
weiter große summen auch in die hand
genommen aber speziell für den
mittelstand ist das die beste hilfe
also mich lieber muss jetzt das
interview set von phoenix verlassen weil
er wird dringend erwartet im
untersuchungsausschuss wirecard da sind
sie ja stellvertretender vorsitzender
und das wollen sie um 9 uhr ohne große
schnappatmung erreichen diesen weiten
weg dorthin vielen dank sie da waren
dieser pause bleibt noch einen moment
bei uns verpasst was ich gerade
angesprochen habe schon bezug auf peter
altmaier scheint ja da das ist hat eine
gewisse tradition die gegensätze
zwischen wirtschafts- und
finanzministerium in deutschland aber
hier gibt es auch offensichtlich einen
politischen machtkampf zwischen olaf
scholz und peter altmaier mann beschwert
sich darüber dass zum beispiel
unternehmenshilfen deswegen zu wenig und
nicht schnell genug fließen weil dieser
masken hat machtkampf das sozusagen
blockiert diese auseinandersetzung
scholz altmaier auch vor dem hintergrund
der bundestagswahl erschwert das lähmt
das das richtige corona
krisen-management ganz offensichtlich
finden das verheerend normalerweise
sollte man ja denken und das gerade wenn
die wahl kommt das dann beide sozusagen
nur gemeinsam dafür sorgen dass das
beste ergebnis heraus kommen dabei wir
mussten leider in letzten monaten
erleben dass sie sich nur gegenseitig
blockiert haben
und das ist eben massiv schädlich für
die wirtschaft ja wenn eben bisher
november helfer dezember hilfe nicht
wirklich ausgezahlt wird wenn man völlig
durcheinander ist irgendwie weil es
jetzt so viele nebeneinander gestückelte
programme gibt dass kein mensch mehr
durchkommt 60 sozusagen schwierigkeiten
habe das zu verstehen dass man immer im
kleingedruckten nachgucken muss nun
sozusagen
da habe ich das beantragen darf ich das
nicht beantragen und für all die solo
selbstständigen und kleinen
gewerbetreibenden beispielsweise den ist
nach wie vor nicht geholfen die den
unternehmer lohnen dürfen sie nach wie
vor nicht absetzen es ist nach wie vor
so dass sie wenn sie 100 prozent zu
machen maximal 90 prozent der kosten
zurückerstattet bekommen das ist die
situation die inzwischen entstanden ist
durch diesen absurden machtkampf
zwischen altmaier und scholz und es wäre
wirklich dringend notwendig dass das
aufhört
wie lange können wir aus den locker und
eigentlich noch leisten da gibt es jetzt
massive diskussionen wie lange können
wir uns noch leisten bevor wirtschaft
oder ohne dass wirtschaft und
staatsfinanzen in die grütze vorhanden
das hängt eben davon ab wie gut die
politik der bundesregierung ist und das
stimmt wir werden jetzt milliarden
schulden aufgenommen aber
wir können uns das tatsächlich also
bundesrepublik leisten was wir uns nicht
leisten können ist nach dem nach der
pandemie eine infrastruktur die zerstört
ist innenstädte die tot sind und das ist
momentan das was droht wir sehen ja
nicht wirklich wie die finanzämter
sächlich ist weil das thema
insolvenzanmeldung ja ausgesetzt ist
aber wir erleben ja schon dass an vielen
stellen jetzt bekannt wird wer sich
alles schon darauf vorbereitet und die
ersten läden sind auch schon zu und
deswegen ist es absurd ein kleines ding
zum beispiel was wir vorgeschlagen haben
ja das eben all die klamotten die jetzt
in den läden sind und für den winter
definitiv nicht mehr verkauft werden
können dass man die spenden kann und
nicht vernichten muss beispielsweise
selbst so etwas ist mit dieser
bundesregierung nicht möglich und das
wird fatale auswirkungen haben für die
innenstadt in unserem land
übriggeblieben interview lisa paus von
den bündnisgrünen finanzplätze sprechen
herzlichen dank dass sie da war liebe
zuschauer es geht jetzt gleich los im
bundestag im plenum erst der
tagesordnungspunkte sind nicht die
steuer hilfe gesetze zur krone sondern
die weiterentwicklung der
gesundheitsversorgung alles weitere
hören wir jetzt aus dem plenarsaal